oh we're getting lots of great reactions
from parents and grandparents of high
school and college graduates all over
the country and that includes my wife
and myself our son
guy i graduated over the weekend from
buena vista university
in storm lake iowa awesome we went from
98 degrees here in las vegas to 48
degrees
super windy was an outdoor event but it
was done so beautifully and they had
hundreds of kids and their parents from
all over the country
a guy was an intern here at eight news
now in the summer of 2019
he's got a degree in digital journalism
and he's
going to be trying to get his first job
in the the tv world here
as soon as we kick him out of the
[Laughter]
we're not gonna do that house he's he's
been a sports broadcaster already
right oh absolutely and and a news
broadcaster he helped the tv station on
the campus kbvu
established a news program he's also
done
entertainment and talk shows he just now
has to narrow his focus and say
well we think he's pretty good at all of
them but you can't do all of those
and sherry he did weather reports for us
remember when they would get hammered
with those freezes so
absolutely he's a junior weather buddy
yeah